[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on disait
dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales de saint gobain russie
ukraine on a beaucoup dit que bon le
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul bert moi je suis convaincu à
titre personnel que il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les plus observés zealand
il faut réduire les émissions de carbone
dans les pays en développement sur
partout partout vous avez construit des
usines décarbonés vos des usines où on
est mais rien du tout comme carbone dans
l'usiné que ce soit nos émissions
directes ou alors des émissions liées à
la production d'électricité nous en
avons aujourd'hui dans dans le monde
donc la conscience écologique aussi
existe en russie
[Musique]
la france doit assumer sa part
d'africanité les mots emmanuel macron
lors du sommet afrique-france un sommet
sans dirigeant intriguant c'est la
société civile qui était mise à
l'honneur et en particulier la jeunesse
du continent
le génial on fait en clôture 30 millions
d'euros sur trois ans pour soutenir la
démocratie
[Musique]
lieu chantant faire respecter ces
principes fondateurs réaction de la
présidente de la commission européenne
après que la cour constitutionnelle de
bologne a contesté la primauté du droit
européen sur le droit polonais mais
bartoli assure vouloir rester au sein
des vingt-sept la sphère pourrait avoir
des conséquences pour le versement à la
pologne des fonds européens de relance
le scandale des ponts de rappeurs
s'invite dans les élections législatives
en république tchèque le vote a commencé
ce vendredi jusqu'à demain l'actuelle
pandémie
est favori andres va bien bénéficiaire
d'un montage financier offshore pour
l'achat d'une résidence de luxe dans le
sud de la france c'est ce qu'a révélé
l'anc est mené par un consortium
international de journalistes
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
c'est un sommet afrique-france au format
inédit qui s'est tenue ce vendredi à
montpellier aucun chef d'état africain
n'était invité une première depuis 1973
la part belle était donné à la société
civile et à la jeunesse
quelques 3000 participants dont plus
d'un millier de jeunes du continent
africain pour des rencontres des
échanges entre société civile africaine
française et diaspora sur des sujets
liés à l'économie au sport ou encore à
la culture arrivé en fin de matinée
emmanuel macron est passé à deux tables
rondes en table ronde interpellé par la
jeunesse africaine sur l'héritage
colonial la politique des visas ou
encore l'aide au développement il a donc
annoncé à en fonds soutien à la
démocratie 30 millions d'euros sur trois
ans pour soutenir la société civile
africaine le chef de l'état qui entend
nouer une nouvelle relation avec la
friction les routes
notre pays s'est construit dans ce
rapport à l'afrique
et nous avons
près de 7 millions de françaises et de
français dont la vie est intimement
familialement de manière directe en 1ère
ou 2ème génération liés à l'afrique ce
qui veut dire qu'on ne peut pas avoir
un projet d'avenir pour la france on ne
peut pas avoir une france qui embrasse
son propre avenir sa propre destinée qui
construit son propre roman national
comme on dit si elle n'assume pas sa
part d'africanité un sommet auquel la rt
france n'a pas pu participer on retrouve
à montpellier samantha ramsamy
bonsoir samantha l'accréditation
d'arreter france a été refusé
alors oui nous avons été refoulé à
l'entrée presse du nouveau sommet
afrique france malgré notre inscription
il y a plusieurs semaines nos
accréditations n'ont pas été acceptées
l'agent en charge des médias nous a
indiqué le motif suivant pas
d'accréditation pour des raisons de
sécurité sur décision de la préfecture
l'actualité ici à montpellier outre ce
rendez-vous au sud france arena avec ce
nouveau sommet afrique france et bien
c'est aussi un contre sommet à
l'initiative de collectif d'associations
et de militants l'objectif c'est de
lutter contre les maux persistant de la
françafrique dans son ensemble c'est ce
sont des manifestations durant plusieurs
jours qui semble déranger les autorités
puisque jeudi plusieurs militants de
défense des sans papiers ont été arrêtés
à la gare à de montpellier à leur
descente du train en provenance de paris
il faut savoir que manifestation est
prévue ce samedi et je vous propose
d'écouter l'une des participantes
mireille fanon mendès-france la fille de
frantz fanon l'une des figures de la
lutte anticoloniale
il ya quelque chose aussi d'un peu
désinvolte de la part de ce président
qui est de faire un sommet france
afrique et dans un sommet afrique-france
pardon et d'en faire un tel battage en
une journée prêtant t'il pouvoir
renégocier ou revisiter la relation
afrique france ont une journée personne
peut faire cela dont on ne peut pas
prétendre que ce sommet va régler quoi
que ce soit si ce n'est qu'on masque une
fois de plus le fait que la france veut
continuer sa sa relation commerciale et
financière et en tirer le plus de
bénéfice et pour ça ils utilisent la
diaspora qui elle même est dans quelque
chose d'ambigu aussi et pour revenir
samantha sur le sommet officiel afrique
france il a été marqué par un dialogue
plutôt franc avec la jeunesse et des
annonces attendues sont sûrs présent
oui lors de se sauver ces nouveaux
sommets plutôt afrique france est bien
assez vrai qu'il ya quand même eu un
dialogue franc entre la jeunesse et
emmanuel macron c'était de toute façon
annoncé et attendu les jeunes qui ont
interpellé le président français sur des
problématiques importantes comme la
démocratie la question migratoire mais
aussi les tensions avec l'algérie et
plusieurs pays du maghreb après la
décision française de réduire
drastiquement elle les visas sur la base
des travaux effectués par l'historien et
politologue camerounais achille mbembe
le chef de l'état a fait plusieurs
annonces il a annoncé la restitution du
patrimoine africain au bénin notamment
et puis la création d'un fonds de 30
millions d'euros pour la société civile
pour soutenir les démocraties en afrique
alors ce n'est pas l'état français qui
va fixer les bénéficiaires ce sera un
comité composé de personnalités de
membres de la diaspora on va quand même
attendre de voir qui sont ses membres
qui seront ses membres quels sont les
réseaux dont ils seront issues pour
déterminer la transparence et la
véritable indépendance de ce futur
comité ce que l'on peut dire pas
d'annoncé finalement fracassante
susceptibles de réellement bouleversé la
donne pour refonder la relation afrique
france merci beaucoup pour ce
compte-rendu samantha ram famille
envoyée spéciale à montpellier pour ce
sommet afrique france
ça sonne comme une nouvelle étape dans
le bras de fer qui oppose bruxelles là
et varsovie la plus haute juridiction de
pologne s'est prononcé hier contre la
suprématie absolue du droit européen sur
le droit national
elles jugent plusieurs articles des
traités européens
incompatible avec la constitution du
pays varsovie affirme pourtant vouloir
rester au sein des vingt-sept bruxelles
réagit et on tente son côté faire
respecter ces principes fondateurs
cyrielle bout et
la pologne dont le viseur de l'union
européenne ce jeudi la plus haute
juridiction polonaise a tranché certains
articles du traité européen sont
incompatibles avec la constitution du
pays une décision de la pologne qui lui
vaut les foudres de bruxelles
nous sommes de plus en plus préoccupé
par l'évolution de la situation en
pologne vous savez que nous sommes
engagés dans différentes procédures pour
défendre l'indépendance de la justice en
fait pour défendre les droits des
citoyens en pologne comme dans tous les
états membres et nous avons maintenant
demander à la cour de justice d'imposer
des sanctions financières en pologne
pour se conformer aux décisions
précédentes sur l'indépendance de la
justice
même si elle remet en cause l'un des
fondements de l'union européenne la
pologne ne souhaite pas la quitter
varsovie affirme vouloir éviter un pôle
excite
l'adhésion de la pologne et des pays
d'europe centrale à l'union européenne
est l'un des événements les plus
importants de ces dernières décennies
pour nous mais aussi pour lui elle même
nous y avons tous gagné c'est pourquoi
je dis clairement la place de la pologne
est et sera dans la famille des nations
européennes
le sort de la pologne reste entre les
mains de la commission européenne qui
n'a pas encore débloqué les fonds du
plan européen destiné à varsovie une
pression financière qui pourrait faire
plier la pologne pour l'y pousser
l'ancien président du conseil européen
et actuel chef de l'opposition polonaise
donald tusk appelle un rassemblement ce
dimanche à varsovie avec pour mot
d'ordre la défense d'une pologne
européenne alors se dirige-t-on vers un
pôle excite écouter ce qu'on pense
françois pour les matières journaliste
spécialiste de l'europe en essayant de
reprendre le contrôle sur la justice
effectivement la pologne de fait se met
à l'extérieur de l'union européenne
pourquoi parce que c'est des choses que
effectivement souvent on ne comprend pas
la primauté du droit européen sur le
droit national c'est quelque chose qui
est une règle commune que tous les pays
les 27 pays de l'union ont accepté de
manière tout à fait souveraine ils ont
accepté de mettre en commun ses
fondements du droit qui fondent
finalement notre règle commune de fait
la pologne est en dehors des clous des
règles de l'union européenne même si
elle affirme ne vouloir y rester on ne
peut pas rester dans une union si on
n'accepte pas les règles de base c'est
un peu ce qui se passe des raisons pour
laquelle
à bruxelles effectivement on envisage
aujourd'hui des sanctions parce qu'on ne
peut pas laisser passer ça effectivement
ça serait la porte ouverte finalement à
détricotage générale l'union européenne
élections législatives en république
tchèque le vote a commencé ce vendredi
il se déroule jusqu'à demain une
élection sur fond de pandora peppers
favori du scrutin le premier ministre
andres baby se retrouvent visé par cette
enquête il aurait dissimuler des avoirs
dans des sociétés off shore le récit de
michael 200 dos en tête des sondages
avec près de 30% des voix andres babiche
et pourtant dans la tourmente alors que
la république tchèque vote ce vendredi
dans le cadre des élections législatives
l'actuel premier ministre est accusé de
fraude présumée
déjà en litige avec l'union européenne
qui l'accusent de conflit d'intérêts
pour avoir détourné plus de 17 millions
d'euros de subventions l'enquète des
pandora peppers lui reprochent cette
fois ci la mise en place d'un montage
offshore pour des achats immobiliers en
2009 avant son entrée en politique
l'homme d'affaires cinquième fortune du
pays se serait offert plusieurs
propriétés dont un château à mougins
dans le sud de la france des opérations
que le leader du parti centriste anneaux
a tenté de justifier devant les médias
tchèques je n'ai jamais rien fait
d'illégal ou de mal c'était une
recommandation d'une agence immobilière
elle a recommandé de lâcheté par
l'intermédiaire d'un avocat ce n'est pas
illégal pourtant ces révélations défini
par le grand favori des élections
législatives comme une campagne de
diffamation menée par ses opposants
politiques pourraient avoir un impact
sur le scrutin déjà affaibli par ses
deux alliés actuels le parti social
démocrate et le parti communiste crédité
de faibles scores ses chances de former
une coalition solide s'amenuisent un peu
plus une aubaine pour ces opposants déjà
très critique au sujet de son
rapprochement avec son homologue
hongrois viktor orban mais aussi à
propos de sa politique nationale
quand je regarde l'avenir du pays je
vois une dette un ralentissement un
déficit budgétaire qui est l'oeuvre d'un
goût ornements dirigé non pas par des
experts mais par l'égo d'un seul premier
ministre donc le remplacement est
absolument vital pour notre avenir
[Applaudissements]
pour être élu et former un gouvernement
andres babiche pourraient être tentés
par une alliance avec le spd le parti
d'extrême droite un mariage qui ne
serait pas vue d'un bon oeil par ses
alliés mais qui pourrait empêcher un
front anti babiche de l'emporter un
groupe d'opposants formée de partis de
droite de gauche et du centre qui peut
compter sur le soutien de près de la
moitié des tchèques agacé par les
scandales du premier ministre
le prochain gouvernement devrait être
moins chaotique je pense que nous
méritons plus d'ordre ici et moins de
corruption
pour tenter de s'en sortir andrés
babiche pourra également compter sur un
soutien de poids celui de milos zeman le
président actuel a d'ores et déjà
annoncé qu'ils aideraient son premier
ministre à former une coalition
lors des négociations post électorale
une taxation minimale à 15% sur les
multinationales réunis sous l'égide de
l'osce et 236 p viennent de trouver un
accord ce soir pour réformer le système
fiscal international les derniers
opposants irlande estonie hongrie et
pologne ont finalement levé leurs
objections ralliant ce projet de
taxation à l'échelle mondiale
l'application de ce taux d'imposition
minimum de 15% aux multinationales
entrera en vigueur à compter de 2023 on
en parle tout de suite avec philippe
béchade rédacteur en chef de la bourse
au quotidien
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france pour qu'on
comprenne bien quels aménagements ont
conduit l'irlande l'estonie la hongrie
et la pologne a rejoint de l'accord
c'était un petit effort bon notamment
pour l'irlande parce que je crois que
sur la planète terre c'est quand même le
pays par lequel transite le plus de
bénéfices
donc l'irlande on consent à augmenter le
taux de 12 points 5 à 15 la bulgarie
fait aussi un bel effort parce que je
faisais c'était 9% donc on va passer à
15 et ainsi de suite pour pratiquement
140 pays enfin 136 pour l'instant on
signe l'accord il manque encore pakistan
kenya le nigeria et le sri lanka a
priori le pakistan devrait se rallier
aux dernières nouvelles le dernier
résistance à 104 le nigeria donc on va
dire que pour l'instant tout le monde
tout le monde à signer sous la pression
américaine notamment et par l
bouleversements à venir à partir de 2023
s'est pas réellement un grand
bouleversement ski et bouleversements
c'est que des pays qu'ils imposaient
pratiquement pas vont appliquer ce taux
maintenant
si on regarde dans le détail ce qui se
passe dans certains paradis fiscaux je
me demande comment cette taxe va être
appliquée alors je pense notamment
à singapour
dubaï le taux sur les bénéfices et 2 0
il ya également les
bahamas antigua et barbuda
donc je ne sais pas si c'est si ces
paradis fiscaux là
vont réellement appliquées appliquer les
taux voilà alors je tiens d'ailleurs à
signaler c'est quand même assez amusant
comme coïncidence qu'elle sait que
jusqu'à vent juste avant que tout le
monde signe l'accord plusieurs paradis
fiscaux ont été retirés de la liste
noire notamment les seychelles par
exemple et vous y voyez un rapport
flagrant
je pense que ces pays là ont dû donner
des gages de bonne volonté
maintenant
ce toqué ce qu'il est censé rapporter
m'écouter c'est assez facile à mémoriser
15 % à l'échelle
de 140 pays ces 150 milliards de
recettes fiscales supplémentaires pour
ces pour ces pays
on va dire que l'essentiel de
l'imposition ou du nouveau système vise
surtout le profit des multinationales
alors réalisant plus de 700 millions de
chiffre d'affaires
là les profits qui sont visés très
précisément ce sont surtout les 500
milliards des centres première
multinationale mondiale et qui ont
toutes entre 20 50 70 filiales dans des
paradis fiscaux or justement ces
multinationales comment est ce qu'elles
peuvent réagir selon vous est-ce qu'il
faut s'attendre à ce qu'elles trouvent
de nouvelles parades
ah ben je crois qu'elles sont même pas
la peine elles ont même pas donné la
peine de trouver des parades je vais
vous citer tout simplement l'exemple
d'amazon
amazon en 2020 c'était 250 milliards de
bénéfices le tout transite par l'irlande
ça ne fait que transiter donc ce n'est
même pas soumis à l'impôt à 12.5 et donc
taux d'imposition 0 alors pour amazon le
diable se niche dans les détails dans
les détails ça ne concerne pas qu amazon
figurez vous que les profits ne sont
taxables qu'au delà d'une marge 2e 10 %
autrement dit si amazon parvient à
limiter sa marge en dessous de ce seuil
dans ces bénéfices ne seront pas taxés
alors on se dit quand même bon en france
on se dit quand même avec gourmandise
que il ya matière à taxation mais
figurez-vous que pour une entreprise
comme amazon qui ne possède que des
entrepôts et où les produits le font que
transiter est bien actuellement
une entreprise de cette sorte n'est pas
considéré comme un comme ayant une base
fiscale stable en france donc il
faudrait que on recale hi-fi l'activité
d'amazon en france par exemple pour
pouvoir les taxer et à condition qu'il
fasse plus de 10% de marge et ensuite
ses marges vont de transit et
éventuellement par l'irlande et là elles
ne seront toujours pas taxer ce qui
pourrait que l'argent reste en irlande
pour subir la position donc quand vous
regardez l'évolution
des gars femmes donc de toutes ces
multinationales qui vont certainement
quand même payer un petit quelque chose
en plus quand vous regardez leur
évolution boursière depuis des semaines
vous voyez que les investisseurs ne se
aucun moment ne se sont sentis menacés
de voir les profits et les futurs
dividendes
en douter très sérieusement par ce
projet de taxation mondiale un tout
dernier mot philippe béchade nous sommes
en plein scandale des pandora paper
c'est ce qu'on peut voir un lien avec
cette décision d'une taxe mondiale qui
finalement fait consensus alors qu'il
était jusque là on l'a rappelé rejetée
par plusieurs pays
oui panama peppers pandora paper
ce projet de taxation
il y a des gens qui travaillent dessus
depuis dix ans
on sait que l'équipe autour de bruno le
maire planches là-dessus également
depuis quatre ans donc on va dire que
ça vient ça vient de loin mais c'est
vrai que ces grosses affaires très
médiatisées
peut-être pas suffisamment d'ailleurs
mais bon pas d'adapter de perth et il ya
dernier en date
ça démontre qu'il ya effectivement des
sommes colossales je vous parlais tout à
l'heure des 500 milliards de profits
dégâts femmes là on est sur un ordre qui
se chiffrent en dix mille milliards vous
voyez donc appliquer effectivement 15 %
taxe sur sur des sommes comme ça et plus
aucun pays au monde n'est pas en déficit
le problème c'est que cet argent là ne
ressortira pas et tant qu'il ne circule
pas et bien il ne sera pas taxée merci
beaucoup pour votre à éclairage ce soir
philippe béchade le rappelle que vous
êtes rédacteur en chef en chef de la
bourse apprécie dhien
elle direction maintenant l'irak qui
tenait aujourd'hui un vote spécial pour
les forces de sécurité les déplacés et
les prisonniers à l'occasion des
législatives anticipées le scrutin
général aura lieu dimanche
il intervient deux ans après des
manifestations de masse contre le
pouvoir accusé de corruption
l'économie du pays est en panne les
services publics défaillants les
observateurs pronostiquent une faible
participation
une partie la population appelle aussi
au boycott
nous avons choisi la voie du boycott
parce que nous avons constaté un
contournement des lois certains ont
décidé de participer aux élections par
conviction personnelle tandis que nous
nous avons choisi la voie du boycott
et nous sommes sortis pour faire tomber
le régime
ne donnons pas de légitimité à ce
pouvoir qui a applaudi et s'est réjoui
des élections ces élections ils vont
tous pleuré à cause de leur
participation
nous nous sommes réjouis après la chute
de saddam hussein en 2003 considérant
que le processus démocratique était
arrivé en irak
mais malheureusement nous avons constaté
que ce processus était fictif faut sans
fondement c'est pourquoi nous avons
essayé la voie électorale
les élections sont un simulacre de
processus sans contenu
en 2019 quand nous avons manifesté nous
sommes sortis dans le but de changer les
choses nous sommes sortis dans le but de
réformer nous ne sommes pas sortis pour
élire ses responsables corrompus c'est
le premier problème le second auxquels
nous avons été confrontés c'est la
répression nous avons été confrontés à
des assassinats nous avons tout
affronter nous avons été confrontés à
des enlèvements et jusqu'à présent les
arrestations continuent nous voulons pas
à dire ces personnes corrompues donc
nous nous contenterons daboiko dimanche
lui d'un nouveau gouvernement c'est le
milliardaire abdel aziz akhannouch qui a
été désigné premier ministre après les
législatives du 8 septembre son parti le
rnd rassemblement national des
indépendants est sorti grand vainqueur
du scrutin la correspondance de bassem
chab
24 nouveaux ministres dont sept femmes
composent l'équipe d'abdel aziz
akhannouch le nouveau chef du
gouvernement considéré comme proche du
roi mohammed 6 qui aura la lourde tâche
de redresser le pays durement touché par
la crise du coronavirus et les
inégalités sociales qui ont marqué
l'ancien gouvernement de saad eddine el
othmani dans ce nouveau gouvernement qui
compte double de femmes que dans
l'ancienne équipe les portefeuilles
régaliens sont reconduits à l'image de
ceux de l'intérieur et des affaires
étrangères
tous deux entre les mains de nasser
bourita ya des lois fille la petite
après la victoire de son parti le
rassemblement national des indépendants
l'homme d'affaires avait annoncé le 22
septembre dernier être parvenu à la
formation d'un goût un amant de trois
parties le sien qui raflent 102 sièges
que compte et 395 du parlement marocain
le parti authenticité et modernité avec
86 sièges eastick halle avec 81 sièges
c'est un nouveau cabinet un mix entre
des ministres chevronnés et des jeunes
compétences le gouvernement se base sur
deux piliers les programmes des trois
partis qui composent le cabinet ainsi
que les conclusions du nouveau modèle de
développement
la priorité aujourd'hui est le programme
gouvernemental qui est prêt et qui sera
présenté au parlement pour obtenir le
vote de confiance 125 sièges il y a
quelques mois contre 12 aujourd'hui les
islamistes modérés du parti de la
justice et du développement à la tête du
royaume depuis plus de dix ans
apparaissent comme les grands perdants
de ce scrutin au profit des libéraux
considéré comme proche de la couronne
nouveau chef du gouvernement devra
présenter son programme dans les jours à
venir devant la chambre des
représentants afin d'obtenir sa
confiance une formalité politique comme
le veut la constitution du royaume du
maroc en pleine crise un mondial de
l'énergie des discussions ont eu lieu
entre la russie et l'union européenne
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov a rencontré
l'association des entreprises
européennes les détails avec maelys
d'estrées correspondante à moscou
lors de cette rencontre annuelle sergueï
lavrov n'a pas manqué d'aborder une des
grandes préoccupations actuelles en
europe à savoir la flambée des prix du
gaz à ce sujet le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères a déclaré que moscou
était prête à aider l'europe à surmonter
cette crise en soulignant toutefois que
le vieux continent ne devait pas
politiser la question du casse écoutez
dans la situation actuelle de forte
hausse des prix des hydrocarbures en
particulier du gaz naturel et de
l'électricité dans les pays de l'union
européenne
il devient évident que nous devons
coopérer de manière beaucoup plus
étroite et systématique dans ce domaine
stern
de manière plus générale la russie prône
une coopération pragmatique avec l'union
européenne et souhaite rétablir des
contacts réguliers avec elle dans tous
les domaines a ajouté le chef de la
diplomatie russe qui regrette la
dégradation constante les relations
russo européennes ces sept dernières
années écoutez
nous n'avons pas de grandes attentes
nous comprenons que les choses sont
actuellement allé trop loin et que
personne ne pourra inverser la situation
du jour au lendemain la confiance a trop
été ébranlé par une série de mesures
unilatérales de la part de bruxelles
mais en même temps nous considérons
qu'il est important de ne pas aggraver
une situation qui est déjà très très
grave
s'est toutefois réjoui que malgré les
sanctions la russie et l'union
européenne restent des partenaires
économiques très importants l'une pour
l'autre et c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi prochain journal
dans une trentaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
résultat un toit peut réserver bien des
surprises pour mieux comprendre où vous
aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
la communication emmanuel mapon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
tik tok est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont il se désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus cooney sq justement c'est
une nouvelle forme de communication
assez verticale utiliser des
influenceurs pour ça comme politique
personnelle est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
aider dans notre intérêt à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques
et sur ces dossiers sensibles je vais
partager avec vous mon interprétation
l'organisation du traité de l'atlantique
nord l'otan a été créée en 1949 pour
défendre l'europe compte une agression
soviétique par une action coordonnée des
pays européens avec les états unis qui
en seraient les chefs
compte tenu de leur puissance militaire